The eye doctor said I need glasses.
I told her, "No way, I will look silly.".
She went on to tell me more.
She said, "Lots of people wear glasses.
They don't look silly.
Some basketball players wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to score a basket.
Glasses help them see better to catch the ball.
Some fire fighters wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to fight fires.
Glasses help them see better to find people in burning buildings.
Some police officers wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to keep us safe.
Some airplane pilots wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to fly safely.
Some cowboys wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to round up cattle.
Even some of your friends wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better to read and write and do math."
Lots of people wear glasses.
Glasses help them see better.
They don't look silly.
They don't look funny.
They look just like me.
I think I'm going to like my new glasses.